the Blue Wave is reforming as a tsunami
of leftist tears as Democrats fall
behind in key midterm election races
president Trump's approval rating hits
an all-time high and Republicans get the
highest score on the economy ever
meanwhile former community organizer
Barack Obama reappears on the campaign
trail to remind us all what an
absolutely insufferable narcissistic
hypocritical empty suit he is all of
which has the Democrats running safe and
weak as the elections approach we will
examine the difference between running
to win and running not to lose finally
why the left always seems to get
Christianity wrong I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael nolo
[Music]
I can't wait to get to that at the end
John Fugelsang
has inspired me to take on why the left
always gets Christianity so wrong or why
it willfully misrepresents it we got a
lot of good news coming out on the
midterm front it is getting real folks
silly season is over the elections are
two weeks away and things are really
heating up you've got to see the
side-by-side of our dueling presidents
president Trump and former community
organizer Obama but first we got to make
a little money honey let's talk about
Robin Hood Robin Hood is an investing
app that lets you buy and sell stocks
ETFs options Kryptos all commission-free
it's simple and intuitive clear design
with data presented in an easy to digest
way this is really useful you need to
download it now there is no Commission
fee other brokerages charge up to 10
bucks for every trade Robin Hood does
not charge commission fees you can trade
stocks and keep all of the profits it
really sets Robin Hood apart I know
you've got to be smart with your money
this is a great way to do it it's got
really easy to use charts market data
you can place a trade in just four taps
on your smart phone I get anything that
takes five taps or more I'm not going to
do I just don't have the patience just
to have four taps and you can learn by
doing you can learn how to invest and
build your portfolio Robin Hood right
now is giving listeners a free stock
like Apple Ford or sprint to help build
your portfolio imagine if you've got a
free stock some free shares of Apple
like thirty years ago you'd be a
zillionaire now you could do whatever
you imagine that you can get all of that
to help build your portfolio sign up at
knowles doubt Robin Hood dot-com ko wles
just like Beyonce dot Robin Hood dot-com
check it out okay great news for the GOP
I'm waiting for a piano to fall out of
the sky
I cannot imagine I can't really fathom
how much good news Republicans are
getting as the midterms approach right
now president Trump's approval rating
has hit an all-time high
that's forty-seven percent and it's
forty-seven percent according to NBC
Wall Street Journal poll you know we've
seen other polls that put him on Daley
presidential tracking polls from
right-leaning firms that say that he's
you know he's doing even better but 47%
from NBC Wall Street Journal is good
crucially it's better than Barack
Obama's at this point in his presidency
it's tracking he's tracking a lot better
than Barack Obama and now this shouldn't
make Republicans and conservatives too
excited because if Barack Obama was trip
trending 46 47 at this time during the
second year of his presidency don't
forget he got absolutely clobbered in
the midterms he got destroyed in the
midterms that's the historical precedent
but right now the GOP has more going for
them than just Donald Trump's popularity
it's helpful because a lot of our local
races now are just referenda on national
figures but also the GOP has the highest
economic approval ratings ever ever
recorded the GOP has a 15-point margin
on Democrats right now it's unbelievable
I mean it's 40-something I think it's 48
to 23 or something like that in terms of
where voters place their trust for
handling the economy Republicans way of
performing them you can tell that
there's a feeling of exuberance on the
right there still is it hasn't gone away
yet so people are running hard the right
is hard charging the right seems to be
running these elections to win I don't
think the left is running these
elections to win I actually think
they're just trying to keep to their
historical advantage and try to rely on
that be dependent isn't working for them
just take a look at our two dueling
presidents President Trump hit the
campaign trail out with Ted Cruz you
know he'd been a little little harsh to
Ted Cruz during the primary elections
said some meet called him lyin Ted said
some mean things about him so a reporter
asks him about this
here's how Donald Trump handles it
[Music]
not lions and what is inevitable
beautiful exit icon Texas Ted Ted Ted
Cruz and I had a very very nasty and
tough campaign whose are very
competitive was a very tough campaign
once it ended and we got together and by
the way very late is the de campaign we
last
people were shocked they said nobody's
really equates to time and then
ultimately what happened we brought it
out the outcome was obvious and we have
worked together very closely I like him
a lot I actually like the village and
he's a very smart guy he loves the
people of Texas which I could look at
that turnaround is he still lying Ted no
he's beautiful Ted what yeah I call him
Texas Ted I thought you called a
beautiful Ted yeah I don't know what I
call him I like him the point is he used
to be bad and now he's good I also love
beautiful Ted because Donald Trump is
very good at these nicknames and
beautiful Ted won it's not an answer to
lying Ted so he's I guess he could still
be a liar right he's not it's not you
now he's honest Ted no no you're saying
his beautiful Ted also because Ted Cruz
has many wonderful attributes he I love
Cruz I did a commercial for Cruz I voted
for Cruz he's not you know
Fabio he's not the bass not like gonna
ride in on the cover of a romance novel
on a white stallion or something like
that so I just love the image oh he's
beautiful Ted he's but what Donald Trump
is doing here is pretty illustrative
because we talk about the politics of
personal destruction these are the
politics usually taken up by Democrats
but we've seen it from Republicans too
it's when things are really personal and
nasty and brutal this is something
people misunderstanding about Trump
Trump gets nasty he's boorish he's
brutal he's savage in his attacks but
it's actually not the politics of
personal destruction so if it were the
politics of personal destruction he
would take it more seriously but he
doesn't take it that seriously he's
going he says he's a liar Cruz is a liar
he holds up his viability a lies lies
lies and then now Cruz is fine he's come
around he says yeah look it was a tough
campaign what do you want me to say
during tough campaigns I say tough
things and now he's good I like him vote
for him it's very clear he saying that's
just about politics it's just politics
don't worry this is not what you're
getting from Barack Obama it's not what
you're getting from any other
politicians really you know it really
these guys take it personally they stick
with it
Barack Obama has hit the campaign trail
again to remind us all how
extraordinarily know
he is he's theoretically stumping for
Nevada senatorial candidate Jackie Rosen
he's really just stumping for himself
here's a quick clip in case you missed
it which you did you guys go ahead and
take a seat I got a lot to say first of
all I have to say that I miss you too
I'm not alone in saying I enjoy coming
to Las Vegas I was backstage fortunately
there were no cameras going when I was
jamming that I want I want I'm here Dee
I can remember in my lifetime and that
includes when I was on the ballot when I
walked in the office 10 years ago
I do think it's interesting I just hope
people kind of notice
folks like meet by the time I left
office and that's what I hand it off to
the next guy now I'd like to bring up
George Harrison Oh through the night I
mean mine I'm you're mine I'm your mine
even those tears I mean mine I mean mine
I mean mine I mean me mine I mean this
clip goes on for two and a half minutes
I played you like 20 seconds of it he
just it's all about me me me and just oh
good grief
get over yourself it reminds me that
he's more narcissistic than Donald Trump
and the thing about Barack Obama is he
was a BS artist par excellence but he
would always keep that serious face and
I think people really don't like that
you know Donald Trump is also a BS or
you know from New York but he's he's
honest about it he says oh yeah I called
him a liar yeah that was cuz I didn't
like him then but now I like him so he's
not he's beautiful now he's Texas Ted
vote for him that's not what Obama does
Obama has to believe the lie cuz it's
about him he can't admit that he's just
engaging in politics he did it's so much
more unctuous it's so much more
disgusting when they do it he also
doesn't talk about Rosen he talks about
IME mine and he's rehashing old he's old
when I was when I was president well I
was but he's fighting old fights and
he's he is gaslighting Republican please
go to every single
State Barack Obama go to every state go
to every congressional district and
remind us why we threw you and your
entire party out of office
he's even rehashing these scandals of
his administration and projecting them
unto Trump and denying that he ever did
them here is it is not a democratic or a
Republican idea that we are not supposed
to pressure the Attorney General or the
FBI to use the criminal justice system
to try to punish political opponents
that's not how America works that's how
some tin-pot dictatorship works that's
not supposed to be America that's not
supposed to be America I mean that's how
my tin-pot dictatorship worked that's
how much when I used the IRS to target
my opponents he used these agencies to
target his political opponents first of
all we know that his executive agencies
were spying on the Donald Trump campaign
and we're getting more and more
information about that day by day we
also know that he's selectively
prosecuted his critics he sent Dinesh
D'Souza to live with criminals for
months and months because he made an
extra donation to a friend of his in New
York who was never gonna win he broke a
law that shouldn't be a law any in the
first place and a law that is virtually
never prosecuted or a crime rather that
is virtually never prosecuted and
Obama's administration threw the book at
him to send a message why because Dinesh
D'Souza made a movie critical of Donald
Trump how about the IRS I was a member
of an organization that was targeted by
the IRS
he used his IRS his tax agency to
intimidate his critics on the right to
intimidate the Tea Party to intimidate
Tea Party organizations and he's doing
that political voice I can't stand that
voice that I think we're all so sick of
it Donald Trump smashed that with his
guttural screaming you know Twitter
voice he has smashed that political
voice you hear him and it's just so fake
it's so artificial and this guy is such
a failure his administration failed it
failed on everything and then President
Trump took office well first the
Republicans took control of the House
and Senate then Trump took office and if
anything got better and that's just what
happened and now he's bitter he's trying
to reclaim a legacy I actually forgot
about him I kid you not I had not
thought about this guy and I don't know
how long because his legacy doesn't
matter it's been dismantled he
systematically lost the entire country
for his political party probably a
thousand seats around the country and
now he's coming back stumping good good
on him please don't do it it's this
hypocritical sanctimony that people are
so sick of and he won't admit he's just
stone cold about oh yeah the DOJ it's
people shouldn't miss misuse the
executive agencies but what about what
no they shouldn't
yeah they shouldn't it's outrageous you
know talk about tin-pot dictatorship
first of all what happened - what
happened to civility remember it's
always they're always calling for
civility when they're not you know
throwing rocks through Republican
congressman's offices or harassing Mitch
McConnell at dinner or harassing people
at their houses or where their children
should sleep they're always talking
about civility then he called our
president our sitting president a tin
pot dictator and he was always awful
this way his attacks on Bush I felt were
out of bounds his attacks on Trump are
are certainly out of bounds to call him
a tin pot dictator and ironic because
Barack Obama behaved in an authoritarian
autocratic way much more so than his
predecessors and ironically much more so
than President Trump we've been told
Trump is going to be an autocrat a
retirement it just hasn't happened if
anything he has ceded power back to
where it belongs before we get into more
of this and more of the Democrat midterm
advantage I got to make a little more
money honey and to invite you into my
boudoir come on in it's fine it's very
nice you know I'm talking about purple
mattress I love purple mattress it has
saved my marriage my you know I got the
California King this thing is incredible
if I was a little skeptical because I'd
read it that it said its firm and soft
at the same time and it's I didn't know
how that was possible it is possible
it's it sleeps really cool and it's not
like memory foam it's got some sort of
memory foam a minute but this technology
that it has what is totally original it
was developed by an actual rocket
scientist you're not going to get it
where you're only gonna get this a
purple mattress and it's just a
different thing it's not like a spring
mattress it's not like a just a foam
mattress it is this different thing and
it is amazing I've been sleeping great
and you know that I sleep 21 22 hours a
day basically when I'm not in this chair
with you I'm lying in my purple mattress
rolling around like a puppy and sweet a
little ELISA likes it cuz the Cal King
means she can sleep as far away from me
as possible you got a hundred night
risk-free trial if you're not fully
satisfied you can return your mattress
for a full refund
backed by ten year warranty free
shipping and returns free free and home
set up an old mattress removal you're
gonna love it right now you got a free
purple pillow with the purchase of a
mattress these pillows are phenomenal
that's in addition to the great free
gifts are offering so why just doing
this right now get your phone out text
qoph FA CoV Fe Fe - 47 47 47 that's the
only way to get a free pillow do it
right now kofi fade COV fe fe - 47 47 47
what is it co v fe fe - 47 47 47 so with
all of this you've got the dueling
presidents President Trump goes out in
Texas he's holding a rally you got a
thousand people sleeping overnight to
get in Barack Obama holds a rally many
fewer people not nearly as big orders of
magnitude less bigger than the Trump
rally what does that tell us
I don't know you know President Trump is
the sitting president he's a much better
showman than Barack Obama we know Oh the
historic midterm advantage is pronounced
Barack Obama in 2010 lost 63 seats
to the Republicans that was in his first
midterm after his election Bill Clinton
lost 54 seats in 1994 to the Republicans
that isn't nothing
you know Democrats only need 24 seats to
retake the house certainly history shows
that they could do that and yet and yet
this is an uncommon election it's an
uncommon president it's certainly
uncommon times economically speaking me
of virtually no joblessness the economy
is screaming right now the thing that
you also got to remember is that what
was it two years ago almost to the day
the New York Times predicted with 92%
certainty that former future president
Hillary Clinton would be
- ninety-two Hillary 8% Donald Trump
what happened it was a Trump blowout it
was a Trump blowout in the election so
these things can change the one reason
that I'd obviously some of these
candidates because they've gotten angry
and they've gotten mad and their guns
stupid certain races the Democrats
should have won or now almost certainly
going to go to Republicans I'm thinking
especially of Heidi Heitkamp up in North
Dakota but the reason I suspect
Democrats don't really believe that
they've got this huge advantage right
now is they're not talking like they're
running to win they're talking like
they're just trying to keep whatever
advantage they have and just play it
really really safe and that's not how
you win here's a Nancy Pelosi explaining
this to CNN if the election were held
today the Democrats would handily win
the happ's I could only speak in the
present tense because you never know in
another couple of weeks look how she's
hedging I mean they learned a lesson
after 2016 you remember the New York
Times predicted 92% Hillary would win
the New York Times had to apologize
because they got that election so wrong
they actually had to apologize to their
readers Nancy Pelosi isn't making
predictions because she wants to hedge
her bets I mean this by by all political
patterns this should be a blowout for
Democrats but it's not looking like a
blowout for Democrats also I'm not
convinced if the elections were held
today that the Democrats would win I
suspect if the elections were held today
Republicans might hold control of the
house we'll see you know she's on the
trail right now I mean she is the leader
of the House Democrats and she's not
using winning rhetoric there are these
two differences when you're playing to
win you are going hard you were breaking
things you are a you don't want to come
in second you don't have anything to
lose you have everything to gain the
great example of this is the Trump of
2016 campaign he was breaking all sorts
of taboos he was running hard on
immigration which conservatives had been
mealy-mouthed on he was running hard on
issues of foreign policy on issues of
foreign trade things that seemed a
little taboo and he was going after them
he was going after political correctness
and he wasn't speaking in a politically
correct way the the example of playing
not to lose the idea of just playing as
safe as you possibly can is Mitt Romney
Mitt Romney well listen to do wind idea
and he's talking and all these long
things that are very boring and he's all
constantly apologizing he won't go after
the moderator do you remember candy
crowley lied the debate moderator Candy
Crowley lied during the Romney Obama
debate interrupted the debate
lied on behalf of Barack Obama to
millions of people watching and what did
Romney do he said well I but but and
Obama's laughing he's sitting there all
go on go on candy go on governor and
she's in there just lying and you know
if Donald Trump had been there can you
imagine what would have happened I would
have blown the roof off the building if
she'd tried to do something like that
that's the difference and you know but
playing not to lose is it not a great
strategy one cuz I don't think it works
very well especially now in our age of
4k televisions and social media
authenticity is really really important
also I don't I don't think she can
really rely on these advantages right
now I don't I don't really see that
advantage playing out in the races where
people are really drilling down and
since Brett Kavanaugh all of the
momentum has been with with the
Republicans so what are they running on
all they're running on his rhetoric and
civility rhetoric and civility this is
ironic there's a Democrat congressional
candidate in Pennsylvania he was having
a debate in a synagogue with Scott a
rather with the GOP congressman Brian
Fitzpatrick and this guy Scott Wallace
told their Republican congressman to F
off in the sanctuary of a synagogue but
he said oh no but civility and a
civility rhetoric civility rhetoric they
can't even run on civility they actually
can't run on civility do you remember
here is Jim Acosta trying to pretend
that the Republicans are the violent
ones I have to tell you Don when the
president made that joke about Gregory
and forte assaulting Ben Jacobs I looked
over to the
there was one gentleman a trump
supporter in the crowd who was doing pro
wrestling moves doing body slam type
gestures in the crowd so the crowd was
obviously eating this stuff up and
people wonder whether or not there's a
cause of affect whether or not the
president's rhetoric you know plants
seeds of violence's and its own
supporters and it is Oh crowds you don't
need the president's rhetoric to plant
seeds of violence you don't see seeds of
violence and the conservative side you
see at 2:00 presumably left wing vandals
throwing a gigantic rock through a GOP
congressional leader Kevin McCarthy's
office window that just happened that
story just broke
you saw that hysterical man baby
screeching at Mitch McConnell and the
restaurant saying what get out of the
country oh please stop it you see Maxine
Waters calling on Democrats she's an
elected Democrat calling on her
supporters to assault her ass
Republicans in the street at restaurants
where they live where their children
sleep Eric Holder did the same thing
Hillary Clinton did the same thing Jim
Acosta doesn't talk about that though
does he so they can't even run on
civility they can't even run on that and
so they're running vaguely on rhetoric
they're basically just running against
the tweets they're running because they
don't like Trump and I'm telling you I
have been on campaigns that have tried
to run against the other guy I've been
on campaigns that have just offered a
negative vision they don't go anywhere
they don't win even if the candidates
better than the other guy they don't win
you have to offer a positive message you
can ding them too you can go negative
you can hit people but you have to offer
them something if you're just running
against the other guy the other guy is
gonna win because the show is about him
everybody is talking about him no press
is bad press if you're just running cuz
he's a bad guy who are you why should I
give you my vote you're always you're
just voting for him so they're making a
huge mistake there the rhetoric thing is
the last refuge of desperate politicians
it's playing it safe
it's it's playing not to lose say Nancy
Pelosi why should we elect you you and
the Democrats to take control of the
Congress well because you have to
historically speaking we're expecting
you to and I'm sorry you asked that
question that's that's her answer she
doesn't have an answer because if you
give an answer you're taking a risk
if you're if you give an answer you have
to stand for something but she doesn't
want you I think you know Mitt Romney
tried to run the 2012 campaign I'm not
being Barack Obama he was trying to run
it on Obama's economy is bad I'm I'm the
other guy elect me doesn't work you've
got to run for something they're not
doing that even these minor Democrat
candidates these Democrat candidates
that we haven't been talking about or
terrible on their rhetoric you want to
talk rhetoric the Georgia gubernatorial
candidate for the Democrats Stacey
Abrams they're just about to have a
debate down there they released a photo
today of her burning the Georgia state
flag they got a photo of her I think she
was in college and she's burning the
Georgia state flag and I'd what is this
with the Democrats now of candidates
running against their states you saw
this with Kyrsten Sinema in Arizona
she's running you know all those videos
popped over saying yeah I hate Arizona
man I hope your states don't turn out
like Arizona and that's why I want to
represent you Arizona in the US Senate
not a great campaign so I don't know I
mean a Democrat political operative
should should take these candidates
aside and shake them a little bit cuz we
couldn't ask for more it's like when you
get a gubernatorial candidate running
who burned the state flag and you got a
photo of it it's like she might as well
take out a gun and start shooting apple
pies and the American flag I mean it's
it's insane and they didn't learn their
lesson this flag issue really matters
people are very offended by this this is
why people don't watch the NFL anymore
this was a major issue another one by
the way that president co fed they got
right which is it's it seems like a
trivial issue to the people who are it
you know the people who are telling you
to stop caring or the ones who say it's
a trivial issue well if it's a trivial
issue why do you care so much stop doing
it well if it's a trivial it's not it's
a really important issue and so it's
really hitting her and then then she
comes out with it this wasn't twenty
years ago this wasn't 25 years ago this
was just on this campaign listen to
Georgia governor candidate Stacy Abram
talking about who her voter Coalition is
going to be but the thing of it is the
Blue Wave is african-american
[Applause]
it's asian pacific-islander it is
disabled it is differently-abled it is
LGBTQ it's veteran yeah it's made up of
those who've been told that they are not
worthy of being here it's comprised of
those who are documented and
undocumented yeah yeah yeah wait wait
what wait what was the last one
you know LGBT no yeah no after that one
documented people nope yet no before
that one sure you're saying that you're
electoral blue wave is comprising
illegal aliens you know that thing that
we've been accusing you guys of doing
for decades now and you say it's
ridiculous and insane
you're Georgia governor candidate just
admitted it then yeah we're gonna round
up all those illegal aliens all the ones
that Trump hasn't deported and we're
gonna get them to illegally vote for us
and put them in the government yeah we
yeah is that great man whoo yeah I mean
those guys they would applaud for
anything in her her campaign office but
it's really incredible a Freudian slip I
think where you say one thing and mean
your mother because she's probably
caught herself here it's oh no I
misspoke or something that's what they
really mean and and voter fraud it is an
issue don't let anybody tell you it
isn't an issue there's a great book out
by Eric Eggers on this called fraud
which you should read all the ways that
the left tries to steal elections so I
don't know what this is is this ignorant
or is this lawlessness or is this both
either way you've got a major Democrat
candidate running on on some combination
of ignorance and lawlessness no surprise
and they're projecting I noticed this at
politican I know you know all the time
at politican you would see these these
left-wing guys if I was on this one
panel with a couple left wingers and
they would interrupt us the
right-wingers when we were speaking they
would constantly interrupt mock you know
cut-in interject and then the minute
that you question something that they
were saying it's they don't interrupt
stop interrupting we need to be civil
but you just you were just old no no now
we gotta be come on come on you we ought
to be civil they project and they
Gaslight I mean it really is gaslighting
when I saw bra
Kabam I started to get a little PTSD
almost you know a little peepee TSD
political post traumatic stress disorder
I just thought oh that it's not one with
it really like affects your emotions
you're just kind of like Oh gross gosh
can we move on from that I thought that
era was over and when Barack Obama says
that they're politicizing government
agencies you just think you did it and
he looks at you stone-cold gaslights no
I didn't know I didn't know we didn't
what are you gonna believe me or your
lying eyes were you gonna believe here
dick durbin is doing exactly this dick
Durbin a Democrat on the Senate
Judiciary Committee here's dick Durbin
talking to Chuck Todd why don't you go
after Republican leaders the way
Republicans go after Democratic leaders
I don't think it's a message that really
carries the day voters are listening for
both political parties to say something
other than a political squabbles
underway in Washington that is that is
that right dick Durbin is that they
don't want personal attacks they don't
want political squabbles in Washington
dick Durbin helped lead the character
assassination into brick Avenue
Judiciary Committee Senate Democrat
helped lead it he was a leading voice
unprecedented character assassination
petty disgusting baseless slander and he
is going ere he says we got they gonna
stop attacking people you know we got to
stop these petty squabbles it's so this
is actually the only thing that they do
that genuinely infuriates me because I
hate it you know don't Buffon my leg and
tell me it's windy don't do it man
don't tell me it's raining you know they
I understand they have stupid policy
ideas they have some confusion about
first principle whatever that's fine I
get it I get the ignorance I even get
the lawlessness
it's just that looking me in the eyes
it's so disrespectful when they do this
and I think I think voters do it too you
know they're living in a fantasy right
now they're living in a fantasy that
they're conning people anymore it isn't
happy to talk about living in a delusion
Hillary Clinton was at an event she was
introduced as you know former secretary
State and as the real president look at
how she reacts who needs no introduction
his former Secretary of State and
presidential candidate she has become
that meme of herself the one where she's
in a straitjacket kind of looking a
wild-eyed and she says I'm the president
I'm the real president the guards say oh
yeah sure you are Hillary yep no come
with us come with us that's what she's
become they say you know you she is the
real president now a normal civilized
sane person who actually cares about our
republic would say no I'm not I'm not
the real president I lost the election I
wish I didn't lose but I lost I'm not
the president what is Hillary Clinton to
say she's the real president yeah she
takes off on her you know broomstick
this is a fantasy world they're living
in and voters don't reward fantasies
they don't not for long
you know full to quote george w bush
fool me once shame on you fool me twice
the point is you're not going to fool me
again they're not reward fantasies they
can sit there and hillary can say i'm
the real president and chuck schumer can
say I'm the real Majority Leader and
they can say they can say that all day
it isn't true it doesn't make it so even
if even if the Democrats retake the
house even if they get their historical
advantage they need to grapple with
reality if they want to rebuild as a
party this is a mission of mercy I'm
giving them free advice president from
radically reshaped politics he really
did at least the political media at
least political communication he he went
in and he grappled with reality part of
that is admitting that you're wrong in
the moment not that you were wrong
thirty years ago but now you got it
right admitting that you were wrong in
the moment Donald Trump did this and it
actually worked a lot of conservatives
because he said oh you were wrong about
this you were wrong about this trade
deal you were wrong about this war you
were wrong about this
it was pretty radical it actually was a
real shaking up and voters rewarded that
they
rewarded a guy speaking bluntly and
speaking directly and not trying to just
make excuses for things that haven't
worked out the Democrats won't do that
they haven't done that what they're
starting to do is they're conveniently
admitting that they were wrong about
certain things so they'll say oh well
yeah the Clintons maybe they weren't
that great when it's only convenient for
them I will give you the answer as to
how the Democrats can rebuild but first
you've got to go to Daley wire comm we
if you're on Facebook and YouTube right
now
head on over if you're on YouTube you
know we just hit a million subscribers
on The Daily wire page that's pretty
cool I think our show is responsible for
what eight hundred seventy five thousand
or nine nine hundred fifty thousand of
those but Ben and drew also contributed
I think like seventy or eighty
subscriptions so that and then another
Kingdom did the rest so that's good but
you know I'm glad thanks to those guys
for helping out and thanks to everybody
for subscribing getting us to a million
subscribers I go over there right now
what do you get you get you get so much
I can't even list it anymore me the
under claiming show the ben shapiro show
you get another Kingdom you get to see
it on Mondays it comes out on Mondays
you get to see it if you're a subscriber
you got to wait for the audio until
Friday if you're not a subscriber but
you get this this is to prepare for the
blue wave the blue tsunami there's you
know we have the leftist years tumblr
it's always getting blue waves they're
always blue ripples salty blue ripples
going through it and as what we were
told was going to be the Democrat
takeover of the entire government as
polling shows that it's going to be more
of a trickle if anything at all get
yours now because we're gonna run out
and then don't come knocking on our door
okay don't come here you're gonna drown
go to Daley wire.com we'll be right back
they've got to grapple with reality
they've got to admit that they are wrong
right now what one what what they're
doing is this this fake posturing I saw
today in the Washington Post by Richard
Cohen he wrote this piece he said I
thought wanita Broderick wasn't credible
I was wrong okay wanita property you
know when he to broader if we had her on
the show
she says that Bill Clinton raped her
I've talked to her I read her book if
you want to talk about credibility this
woman's got it
she's she's got people at the time that
she told about this her story has never
changed even NBC News admits her story
has never changed she just seems
credible she doesn't seem kooky she
hasn't lied publicly about major things
she did only one time the only sort of
hole in her story is she once said under
oath that it didn't happen when she
wanted it to go away then once the story
leaked she admitted it happened but
that's the only thing close to it she's
never changed her story since but
Democrats wouldn't talk about her
wouldn't accept it now all of a sudden
we've got Cohen saying oh yeah maybe I
believe her now he says quote I remember
refusing to deal with Broderick's
allegation because I simply chose to
believe Clinton was not a rapist Clinton
after all was one of us college-educated
modern urbane and not some hooded
monster preying on strangers men like
that do not rape my position has proved
naive violence can be in the sexual
repertoire of any man sure he goes on I
am no longer certain that Clinton did
not rape Juanita Broderick well good job
good job mr. Cohen and Washington Post
now that the Clintons are not only
politically useless to you to the party
and to the left more broadly but
actually now that the Clintons are a
liability now you're willing to stand up
and say oh yeah maybe that guy did it
after decades of flying cover for these
people after just two years ago trying
to put this man back in the White House
and put this woman in the Oval Office
the woman who smeared all of Clinton's
accusers and victims as a bimbos
after just doing that wasn't 20 years
ago that you did that that was 2 years
ago
that you you all were doing that now you
say oh you know I'm starting to believe
her great oh great can great let's throw
them a party wow that now you must be
super serious no way no way buster I
hear these things all the time
they'll people will ask how can we unite
the country how can we be civil how can
we come together and unite and agree on
this and this and this they got to come
to the table the left has to come to the
table you know we don't kick their
speakers out of college campuses we
don't scream at them we don't even call
them racist even though many of their
policies in fact are quite racist we
don't call them evil we don't call them
wicked we don't throw rocks into their
houses we don't harass them in public
you got to come to the table guys and if
you're going to offer something which is
now a political convenience for you from
actions that happened 25 years ago give
me a break
put up or shut up and don't don't boof
on my leg and tell me it's windy you
know don't lie to my face
don't Gaslight me give me something real
until then I don't believe it it's just
not believable you know speaking of
politican I got to meet John Fugelsang
there and I rather liked John Fugelsang
he's this lefty actor comedian guy but
he seems like kind of a nice guy he's
dead wrong about many things and this
gave me the privilege or misfortune of
coming across John Fugelsang take down
viral occupy Democrats video about how
Republicans are fake Christians they're
not real Christians because Jesus was a
left-wing hippie don't you know and I it
occurs to me that the left always gets
Christianity wrong always misrepresents
Christianity take a look at this we'll
go through a point-by-point wouldn't it
be great if we could find a way to get
Jesus of Nazareth to come back and run
for president on the GOP ticket they
can't pick a front-runner anyway so
wouldn't the GOP love to get behind a
guy who was a peaceful radical
nonviolent revolutionary who hung around
with lepers hookers and criminals who
never spoke English was not an American
citizen a man who was anti capitalism
anti wealth anti public prayer yes he
was Matthew 6:5
anti-death-penalty but never once
remotely anti-gay didn't mention
abortion didn't mention premarital sex a
man who never justified torture who
never called the poor lazy who never
asked a leper for a copay who never
fought for tax cuts for the wealthiest
Nazarenes and was a long haired brown
skinned that's in Revelations homeless
middle eastern Jew of course that's only
if you believe what's actually in the
Bible
boom Fugelsang out boom mic drop got you
Christians got you 2000 years of the
Catholic Church boom except it just
isn't true so let's go through a
point-by-point
he starts out he says Jesus was a
peaceful radical nonviolent
revolutionary he's probably referring to
turning the other cheek Jesus says to
turn the other cheek when somebody slaps
you and offends you what we see there is
a personal humility and a spiritual
defiance when somebody offends you you
will not let them control you you will
not let them degrade you and you will
not retaliate in some irate revenge you
will have personal humility and
spiritual defiance he is not talking
about pacifism in a national sense he
was living in an occupied country the
idea of abandoning one's right to
self-defense one's national right to
self-defense or one's political right to
self-defense would have never even
entered the political lexicon of the
times he also told his apostles to sell
their cloaks and to buy a sword in only
certain places when you're like John
Fugelsang and you just point to certain
places of the gospel you can twist it
and pervert it and make it look like a
you know like you're looking at the
Bible into a shallow well and all you
see is your own reflection but when you
look in other places
Jesus says sell your cloak and buy a
sword jesus also says that he comes not
to bring peace but a sword how about
being a radical you know Jesus is
radical in Salvation absolutely but he's
not radical in religion he explicitly
says he's not radical in religion he
says I have not come to abolish the law
I have come to fulfill the law that we
will not change one jot or tittle
until the end of the ages okay then
Fugelsang says we you know Jesus hung
around lepers and hookers and criminals
absolutely right you're right he Jesus
never once condemned individuals as
deplorable and irredeemable great point
what he did was save them he also told
them to sin no more so he hung around
all of these people but he didn't
indulge in sin he didn't say oh you're
you're perfect just the way that you are
stay exactly the same and keep on
sinning he he tells people what they sin
he doesn't condemn them for it he saves
them but he tells them to sin no more he
never spoke English and he's not an
American citizen that's true he was a
citizen of his own country that was
controlled by the Romans and actually
Jesus was born in Bethlehem because his
mother was on the road to go register
with the government that is a point that
I think mr. Fugelsang missed and it
seems like the opposite of the point
that he was trying to make but you're
right he didn't speak English and was
not an American citizen which I don't
think anybody has ever suggested
everybody knows he was Italian anyway
right I'm not true Fugelsang says that
he was anti capitalism and anti wealth
Jesus doesn't talk very much about
capitalism one reason for that is that
modern capitalism didn't develop for
nineteen hundred years after the
incarnation of Christ he's not anti
wealth though he's not anti wealth
people mistake this all the time
money is not the root of all evil the
love of money is the root of all evil
being possessed by wealth being
possessed by your own possessions that
is evil that is a danger that will make
it harder to get into heaven than it is
for a camel to pass through the eye of a
needle
absolutely but he doesn't tell everybody
that he meets to sell all of their
possessions he tells certain people who
were possessed by their possessions some
other people he says go out and buy
something go out go to that fish and put
you know go pull a coin out of a fish
and this also brings me to my fit one of
my favorite parables the parable of the
talents also the parable of the hedge
fund manager which is when the master
goes out and he gives three servants
some money and then he goes away and he
comes back after a time and the one
servant turned his his money into a lot
of money he invested it he got a good
return on his investment
the second servant made
little bit of money you know he got a
decent return and the third servant
buried it underground because he was
afraid of the master and didn't want to
risk losing the money and what did the
master do he took the wealth from the
the poor servant and the unprofitable
servant and gave it to the rich servant
because for he who has much more will be
given and from he who has a little even
that little which he has will be taken
away and then the master casts the
unprofitable servant into hell where
there is weeping and gnashing of teeth I
am NOT suggesting that this is a
diatribe
on modern economics I'm just pointing
out that John Fugelsang is miss reading
the Bible and selectively quoting it to
suit his own political purposes he says
that Jesus is anti-public prayer this is
because Christ in the gospel says do not
be as the hypocrites making a show of
yourself and praying for the applause of
men go into your closet when you pray go
into your clinic closet of your closet
and hide yourself and pray to God sure
that's all true you shouldn't be like
the hypocrites this doesn't mean that
you can't pray in public in fact Jesus
prays in public many times through the
gospel narratives one wonders if John
Fugelsang has read them or if he's just
misrepresenting them and then he says
he's anti-death-penalty
I assure you Jesus is not
anti-death-penalty
death but the death penalty was the
mechanism of salvation Jesus came in the
world to suffer the death penalty and on
that cross conquered death and redeemed
mankind this is the central joy of the
world the happy fall redeemed in the
resurrection of Christ he he later
foretold Peters death on the cross he
also said render to Caesar what is
Caesar's and we have st. Paul writing
extensively about how the civil
government has the authority of the
sword it has the authority of capital
punishment in Scripture which is
inerrant this has been affirmed time and
time again by the greatest doctors of
the church for 2,000 years and John
Fugelsang
has no idea what he's talking about not
scripturally not theologically and not
as a matter of the writings of the
doctors of the church then Fugelsang
says that Jesus was never anti-gay yeah
sure who is anti-gay who was anti point
to someone who's anti-gay Muslim
terrorists who throw gay guy
off of buildings in the Middle East they
would be anti-gay I think that counts as
anti-gay Christ cut he comes he hangs
around with sinners he redeems mankind
now why do i think john fugelsang
probably is attacking republicans for is
defending marriage defending traditional
marriage against redefinition to include
same-sex unions you know Christ speaks
explicitly on very few pressing tangible
issues in the Gospels there are few
things where he speaks explicitly
clearly and one of those things is
marriage he says it very clearly a man
and woman were created they are meant to
leave their families come together and
become one flesh and what God has joined
no man can separate he defines marriage
perfectly and there's nothing hateful or
unchristian about the way that Christ
defines it
he then a Fugelsang says he doesn't
mention abortion or premarital sex he
does he actually does do that he says
whosoever shall offend one of these
little ones it would be better for that
man to have a millstone hung around his
neck and for him to be cast into the sea
and throughout the Gospels Oh throughout
the Bible rather we hear a God talking
about knowing people before they were
even formed in the womb knowing about
them before before they were born before
they were formed in the womb st. Paul
writes about this about being called by
grace while he was being formed in the
womb this is thread scripture and just
in case mr. Fugelsang says well Jesus
didn't say that thing from the Old
Testament directly Jesus is God the
Trinity I certainly am incapable of
explaining the Trinity here or elsewhere
but God is three persons in one divine
unity so he who had as it says in the
gospel as Christ says he who has seen me
has seen the father then he says he
never justified torture again torture
justifies us that torture of the cross
justifies we human beings and redeems us
and saves us it gets it entirely
backwards who would justify torture he
uses the cross to justify us he then
says he that Christ never called the
poor lazy nobody calls the poor lazy
nobody does some people on the right
call lazy people lazy they certainly do
that or they call timid people timid or
scared people scared
absolutely so does Christ Christ was
offended when the Gospels couldn't stay
awake while he was praying in the garden
he's constantly is speaking of endurance
he's saying you have to endure until the
end can't be lazy don't be lazy Christ
speaks against laziness countless times
and again he casts that poor
unprofitable servant into the fire where
there is wailing and gnashing of teeth
Fugelsang says that Christ never asked a
leper for a copay right Christ also
never demanded that Caesar render unto
lepers the labor of others he certainly
never suggested that anywhere and
neither did the Apostles neither have
the Church Fathers it's absurd and it's
ridiculous to make a shallow political
point from that he says that Christ
never fought for tax cuts that's true
but Christ paid the minimum tax
he made the minimum tax he possibly
could he was asked to try to entrap him
they said will you pay the tax and he
said whose name is on the coin render to
Caesar what Caesar's render to God what
is God plucks the tax out of a fish and
he also didn't fight for tax hikes and
finally he said that he was homeless
Christ was never homeless Christ was in
this world to save mankind but he his
kingdom is of another world and we are
not homeless we're pilgrims and that
distinction makes all the difference and
it really tells me a lot of how the left
like John Fugelsang misunderstand
Christianity and misrepresented
constantly and there's this irony
they're always telling us you know at
Christianity is a bunch of fables and
old tall tales told to shepherds
thousands of years ago and also you get
it wrong and here's what it really means
and I know everything about it Jesus was
a great guy which one is it guys pick a
lane but the Democrats can't pick a lane
we got a lot more to talk about but I'm
running too late so we'll get to it
tomorrow
in the meantime I'm Michael nose this is
the Michael Nolt show I'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Joshua alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you